hello everyone as everyone is preparing
for the World Chess Championship match
in November between Magnus Carlsen and
Fabiano Caruana it's interesting to see
how the world champion and the World
Chess Championship Challenger are
preparing for their bit before their big
matchup as you've seen Fabiano corner
did play the Olympiad and he did play
all the games and he did an excellent
score while carlson was training in his
secret camp and now well some month
before the World Chess Championship
starts here we have cousin he's playing
in the European team chess club
competition so he he got offers from a
lot of clubs to join them but he refused
all of them and he's playing for the
vålerenga shark club from Oslo for free
so of course he doesn't need money and
no Club has that much money that he
would change his mind due to money so
the championship is being played here
it's a holiday
it's a Greek holiday resort in Porto
chorus as you can see it's very nice so
if you're you know if you study really
hard and become an excellent chess
player you will also be able to visit
nice places such as these so without
further ado Magnus Carlsen faces a
Russian Grand Master Vladimir Putin on
the first onboard one and he decided as
he skipped around one he said that he's
just here to relax before the match and
perhaps help out his teammates if needed
so this is a pretty tough matchup so he
decided to help so without further ado
Costin has the white pieces and he opens
with E for we have E 5 night we have
three Knight to c6 and Bishop to c4 here
we have Bishop to c5 at the jaco piano
game and here comes b4 this is the Evans
gambit but it was not played in this
game here cousin played c3 he went into
the main line of the Joko piano and 90
to f6 now we have the main line d3 we
have d 6 9 B to d2 this is all standard
we have castles b4 Bishop to b6 and now
Bishop to Bishop to b3 preparing to meet
Bishop three six with bishops
the situ but also making room on c4 for
this night you want to go in 94 and then
grab the bishop on b6 the dust winning
the bishop pair also we do have some
live footage from this event now if you
remember Nicky Riga we've checked out
her photos during the 2018 candidates
tournament here we also have some live
footage from this event so there you
have it I don't know I've never actually
used the video in OBS but it should work
pretty nicely there you have it this is
a footage from this game it was awesome
and I have no idea if this will if this
will show correctly but I hope it does
so there we have it and let's continue
with the game we have nice to e7 knights
the CC for now as planned going for the
dark square Bishop Knight to g6 and now
castles we have c6 in increasing the
pressure against the d5 but also perhaps
if Carlsen doesn't capture perhaps this
Bishop can also come to c7 so across and
decides to grab it we have Knight
captures pawn captures and now a 4 so of
course it has the bishop repair but in
exchange your black has a semi open a
file rook to e8 and dena comes in Bishop
to e3 Bishop to e6 across and avoids the
exchange Bishop to see - and then out
comes d5 and okay we have a ch3 Queen to
c7 and now rook to e1 h6 and now comes
he captures on d5 Knight captures on d5
and now better back to d2 not allowing
the knight capture but also guarding the
c3 pawn bishop to f5 and here after a
lot of consideration cross in place d4
the engine agrees with caution and going
into all of these exchanges will be as
you'll see favorable for white Bishop
captures on c2 Queen captures on c2
enter now he captures on d4 Knight
captures on d4 and now c5 it seems like
white just gave black an opportunity to
end up his pawns but actually
this will all be all be fine be captures
on c5 pawn captures on c5 and not Knight
to f5 and now you see that cousin has a
very nice f5 square for his Knight and
it will not be all that easy to
challenge it here Knight G to e7 ISM is
possible to keep the knight wire or
force another series of of trades but
then c4 seems to be a very nice move and
black decides against this so after
Knight to a5 we have Queen to c6 and the
now comes c4 by Carlsen nonetheless
Knight d2 F for crossing trades of a
pair of rooks rook captures on e8 look
after Sonny 8 and now Bishop captures on
f4 night chapters on f4 and now Knight
back to e3 cutting off the rook from
controlling D file also controlling the
c4 pawn defending it and perhaps I have
this Knight has ever kicked away perhaps
even planning Knights to d5 but for now
you do have to keep an eye on the g2
pawn if you move the night then Queen
Capra's on g2 will be checkmate so rook
to d8 and now comes look to be won a
nice semi open file for the rook perhaps
ideas like a5 and rook to b6 are coming
and also black has to keep an eye on the
b7 pawn at all times here it seems like
the b6 would have been the best idea for
black not allowing Carlsen to put this
one in any further 285 but here what can
have a different idea he played h5 wood
ideas of pushing this point all the way
to h4 really stifling that white king
cousin grabs this opportunity as b6 was
not placed to play a5 grabbing even more
space we have eight 4s planned and now
comes Luke to b6 a very active move by
Carlsen but the engine gives a queen to
f5 is even better with a double attack
against this night and against this pawn
and only then does a rock lift come into
the game so after we defend an
idealistic Queen c7 now comes look to b5
and here it's it will be a much better
position for white cousin's idea is a
bit different he goes rook to b6 with an
attack on the Queen and now Queen to d7
Queen to be two now creating a double
attack against the b7 pawn and here we
have nice to d3 attacking call since
Queen you do have to rear
- this queen to be one again the b7
point is under attack and here nice the
before this seems to be the first
mistake of the game by mr. bodkin the
correct idea would have been to play
queen to a 4 with a double attack
against the a 5 point and against the c4
pawn that's currently guarded by the
knight but okay you're threatening Queen
captures on a5
so now after rook captures here Queen
captures Knight comes to d5
you have Queen to e1 check black can
force a trade of Queens and after
captures captures Knight to e7 check
King h7 and now after Knight to f5
attacking the age for pawn g5 is coming
and here it would seem that the the
material on the board is completely
equal and it seems that black will be
able to hold this but again instead of
the squint way for a four move we had
Knights to be four on the board now the
knight is cutting off the Queen's
influence and the rook a person b7 is no
longer an option but now cousin takes
the advantage and plays Queen to e4 now
I'm the b7 pawn all the way from efore
so again this is a big threat Queen to
d4 offering a trade of Queens and here
across and accepts this Queen captures
pawn captures and rook characters and
before we have pawn captures on e3 f
captors an e3 and now troop the d1 with
check came to f2 and now rook to e1
going after the a 5 point and here
across and simply in defends it rook to
b5 rook to e8 you check King to f3 and
now g6 we have c5 by Carlson and now
came to g7 and here across some place
King to e4 Healy leaves the g2 pawn
unguarded but he doesn't care about the
g2 poner about the King side at one
point he wants to play rook captures on
b7 and then start pushing both of his
passed pawns here rook captures and g2
was played but waiting for Carson to
capture on b7 wouldn't have been any
better it's hard to make a move you
can't move the f1 well ok you can play a
5 but that's a bit too much if f6 then
real captures on b7 would check if you
try to go away with the King for example
King to h6 to go this way again you kept
from b7 and then again
the f7 pawn is unguarded I mean if you
try something like King f6 just rugby 6
share King goes back route capture son
b7 rook captures on a5 and now you can
start pushing your pawn rook the c5 you
can start pushing the pawn here and here
white would be winning
I would say King f6 King to d4 attacking
the rook and now you would simply play
King to d5 and prepare this maneuver
this will even come with check plays the
rock here and doesn't really matter you
will simply block off the black rook and
you will be able to promote your pawn
so after King to e4 not waiting for
Carson to grab here but the bottom
starts capturing pawns on the Kings side
rook captures and g2 will capture some
b7 and now g5 we have c6 cousin simply
starts pushing his passport g4 now
watcing wants to create a passed pawn
off his own we have c7 and now rook to
c2 putting a rope behind a passed pawn
but it doesn't help him King to b3 and
now look to c1 i playing something like
g3 wood ideas of sacrificing the rook is
pointless because after we push the pawn
cross and we'll simply go rook to be 1
and cover the G 1 square so after king
to d3 now we have rook to c1 and now
comes King to d2 rook to c6
we have a 6 of course you cannot capture
it because then the C the C pawn can be
promoted as the rope will no longer be
guarding the c8 square so after a 6 we
have G captures on h3 and now a 7 now a
8 is a big threat
we have h2 and now feel free to pause
the video here and find the winning move
for white I'll give you a couple of
seconds to do it you know feel no
pressure whatsoever for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are in excellent and game player and for
those who just wanna enjoy the show the
move is looked to be 1 simply preventing
black from from promoting his pawn to a
queen if you try to promote your own
point to a queen and allow black to
promote his pawn to a queen this this
would be terrible for white so hopefully
you all found rook to be one this is
move 49 and it was in this position that
Vladimir Putin decided to resign
game as the game finished not so long
ago I don't have the result of the
entire match but we're gonna cover of
course a couple of more games throughout
the entire European team Chess
Championship so we're gonna talk about
the results some more so there we have
it like I said we don't have some new
photos here we have a nice photo of
Magnus Carlsen and Vladimir Watkyn from
this game or both of them are from the
video taken by Nikki Riga for those of
you who have been following my channel
since the 2018 candidates tournament you
don't you do know Nikki this is Nikki I
will put the links to her social media
profiles in the description below so
feel free to check it out as she does
have some excellent photos from a lot of
chess tournaments she's now the official
photographer here so feel free to follow
her as well so there you have it I would
also like to thank Joshua Burley Ricky
brown Christopher herbs Jeffrey Clayman
and Ricky Brown for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos your thing call for watching and
I'll see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content thank you all
and I'll see you soon